- Salut Fabien Olicard !
- Salut à vous peuple des internets.
- Alors là, littéralement, on pourrait penser qu'on a pété..
*rires*
- C'est vrai, alors que ce n'est pas moi !
Je suis de retour sur cette chaine avec la merveilleuse Lola Dubini, la  LOLA DUBINIIIIII  !!
- Bonjour !
j'ai fait le même "Lola Dubini" que celui que j'ai fait y'a un an et demi.
vidéo... dans cette description, et également
vidéo sur ce petit "i" là haut
je pointe toujours droit quand j'ai un doute de où es-ce que le "i" apparait
- moi j'fait sa : *fait l'oiseau* comme ça, ça englobe
- mais j'crois je rajouterais une flèche en post-prod
qui partira du doigt pour aller au même endroit
-qui fe fiuuiuuu.. ok
c'est la fin de cette vidéo: merci à tous  d'avoir suivi
*Fabien chante*
- On viens de faire une vidéo sur ta chaine.
-Oui.
euh..
- qui s'affiche également là haut et qui est également
dans la description de cette vidéo.
C'était une vidéo sur le thème du mensonge
on a uttilisé des cartes avec euh des
y'avais des pouce en bas
y'avait également des pouce en l'air
et en fait ces cartes-là, euh c'est des cartes qui ont été créées
par des potes, que je cite qui s'appellent Maxime et Sylvain
ils ont créer les cartes à jouer qui étaient toujours avec des trucs de réseaux sociaux des trucs comme ça
merci pour cette créativité messieurs.
*rires*
-débordante.
donc quand on reçois un sms y'a toujours une bonne nouvelle
ou une mauvaise nouvelle qui se cache derrière...
-c'est vrai.
... et quand on voit apparaitre le logo de ce sms on sait pas exactement,
on essaye de deviner de pré-sentir
- on est émoji comme sa "😮"
- exactement.
et alors le deuxième constat c'est que..
aujourd'hui on envoie des sms en permanence
on est un peu addict à ça et cætera
on se laisse même perturbé,
y'en a qui envoient des sms en conduisant ce qui est extrêmement dangereux...
-très dangereux ne le faite pas absolument pas
-d'autre pendant qu'on converse ce qui est extrêmement... 👈
chiant !
- chiant ou dangereux si le mec en face est un peu vénère et qu'il le prends mal
et bien, on va se faire un test autour de tout ça
-ok
-c'est a dire que moi je vais te perturbée en récitant les décimales de PI
parce-que je crois que c'est un plaisir
- *cafouillage* a c'est vraiment
j'ai deux passions dans la vie :
1: les tacos 🌮
2 : et récité les décimales de PI π
bah... bèh pareil, tu vois ? et.. c'est dans l'autre sens
j'met PI π d'abords avant les tacos 🌮
-ah d'accords ok
-et sa dépends si y'a d'la mayo.
*rire*
et donc j'vais te perturbée et toi pendant ce temps là tu vas
essayée de triées ces cartes, tu vas les triées mais tu vas les triées a l'instinct.
- ok ?
c'est à dire tu va pas euh
- ah tu veux dire je ne vais pas regardé le pouce
-tu vas pas regarder
tu vas essayer de faire comme t'aimerai que ce soit toi en fait
es-ce que tu penses que c'est une bonne nouvelle ou une mauvaise nouvelle
tu vas les foutres comme ça en deux tas
un coup à gauche, un coup à droite, un coup à droite un coup à gauche.
peut être deux ici, trois là.
-de toute manière je ne peux pas deviné puisque
je n'ai aucun moyens de savoir. Les cartes sont retournées.
- Exactement
dés que je commence a récité PI π, tu commences à le faire
au lieu de regarder tout le temps ce que tu fais, tu cherches à me regarder en même temps
c'est comme sa que je vais te perturber en fait
-d'accord
-comme si tu étais en voiture ou en train de faire autre chose
et que tu t'occupais de tes sms.
Et en gardant quand même en toi,
le coté instinctif de  es-ce que je pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle ou une mauvaise nouvelle
très bien. Je n'sais pas du tout ce que j'vais deviné.
-prête Lola Dubini ?
-alors j'me sens prête mais il ne m'a pas prévenue de ce qu'on faire donc..
je.. la je... j'y vais comme on dit à l'aveugle
-ouais, c'est le but !
-très bien..
donc là j'te regarde
-ouais, moi j'vais te dire, 3,1415926535
8979323846
2643383279
euh, euh 5028841971
-vérifie si c'est vrai hein
6939937510
505820974944
euh, j'en suis où ah ..
-c'est bon
t'as fini !
-c'est les vrais ?
-ouais tout à fait ouais
-mensonge
-nan j'te jure
- pouce en bas
-alors vérifiez, verifiez...
-vérifiez, si j'vous en supplie vérifiez
-... et dites lui dans les commentaires
et j'me suis arrêté à 4944 donc après ça aurais été :
5923078164
et cætera, et cætera.
-mais comment tu les a appris
-pfffiouf tu sais...
-l'habitude
-...moi j'ai une petite vie d'enfer
et passionnante hein
-nan mais...
alors tu m'a fait les deux tas comme ça, ok.
-oui !
on va pas encore regardée comment t'as trié, y'a euh...
là y'a que vous qui allez les voire hein ! y'a; vous avez ces deux smileys juste ici
tu va les mélangés face en bas
-ok
-j'veux pas que tu sache qui est où.
-bien sûr
-et tu vas en poser un ici devant et un ici devant
donc la pour l'instant c'est uniquement le hasard et pas mes capacitées donc ...
... ne jugez pas mes capacitées s'il vous plait
-ou peut être que
tu a des capacités cachées
-bien sur euh c'est évident
- au départ j'ai mélangé. J't'ai donné sa
t'as fait comme tu voulais, en me regardant, en te laissant perturbée
-ah là vous l'avez vu hein
alors je t'ai donné les deux smileys tu les mis dans l'ordre que tu voulais
-c'est toi qui a choisi
-je les ai pas regardé donc euh, je n'sais pas
d'accord, j'vais juste vérifié y'avais 18 cartes,
voir si tu as fait quelque chose d'à peu prêt égal je vais compter combien on en a ici
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
c'est merveilleux.. t'en a 9 d'un coté
et 9 de l'autre
et je n'ai pas calculée
déjà d'instinct...
...tu as mis exactement autant à gauche qu'à droite.
j'aime beaucoup
-ok.
maintenant on va découvrir
ici tu nous as mis le smiley triste 😢 plutôt une mauvaise nouvelle
et ici le smiley qui sourit😀 donc plutôt une bonne nouvelle
-d'accord
on va voir, dans ton tri...
-on est d'accord
si ça corresponds ou pas, ce qui serait déjà un petit peu ouf
oui là, ce serait un petit peu trop
là par exemple, juste en face
du smiley qui sourit 😀 t'as mis un pouce en l'air 👍
-*rire nerveux* nan mais non
et en face du smiley triste 😢 t'a mis un pouce en bas 👎.
En même temps
euh y'avait que quatre possibilités, c'est à dire que ce soit:
°deux rouges
°deux bleus
°un rouge un bleu dans ce sens
°ou un bleu un rouge dans l'autre sens
t'avais une chance sur quatre, d'avoir cette config
-ouais ouais *rire nerveux*
oui.
-mais c'est pas si mal
-je sens que j'suis en train d'me faire euh.. c'est d'la magie
-non, puisque je ne touche à rien
-non ? c'est vrai
c'est ça qui est drôle
-okey
et juste ici par exemple tu as un smiley triste
-nan *rire*
un smiley triste un smiley triste un
on peut vérifié ici aussi un petit peu on a un smiley en l'air un pouce en l'air
on a encore un pouce en l'air et puis tu sais quoi on va
on va même tout étalé ce sera beaucoup plus simple
on a du smiley triste ici à foison
et du smiley en l'air ici à foison
Lola Dubini
je n'sais pas comment vous avez fait
mais d'une manière ou d'une autre vous avez un instinct surpuissant
ou quelqu'un vous a manipulé en récitant les décimales de PI
je n'sais pas on n'sais pas et pour une fois j'vais pas vous expliquer
parce-que ça fait plaisirs aussi de ce faire un peu bluffé sur la chaine
je crois que je n'avais pas fait sa depuis 2 mois
et ça fait extrêmement plaisirs
-*rire* nan nan mais moi j'aimerai
tu vas pas l'expliquer du tout ?
-nan pas du tout non
mais alors là vraiment si vous comprenez euh mettez un commentaire mais c'est ..
fin je n'comprends pas là
-en vrai moi non plus j'ai prié toute la nuit pour que ça fonctionne
bah écoute t'a bien prié ça a fonctionné
et ça a fonctionné
-prie pour que je gagne beaucoup de sous s'il te plait
en vrai j’étais pas sur que ça fonctionne à ce point
*rires*
que ce soit un sans fautes
mais pour le coup c'est un sans fautes
-ouais c'est un sans fautes au delà du sans fautes quoi
j'pense que tu a des ressors cachés en toi que tu ne connaissais pas
oui...
oui on va dire...
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
on va rester sur cette info
*rires
-et j'te rappelle que t'a aussi fait le tri exact, 9 de chaque coté
pas un de plus, pas un de moins.
-nan mais nan.. si ça se trouve c'est..
finalement c'est moi qui suit bluffé de toi.
-pffuuu *rires*
mais ça tu le saura jamais
-nan, nan mais j'aime pas ta chaine
à chaque fois j'me sens ridicule quand je parle
-naaan 😇
on aurais du terminer par ma vidéo Fabien
c'est.. c'est pas faux
*rires*
écoutez, je propose en soutien, en consolation pour
Lola Dubini que vous lui laissiez ce magnifique
pouce en l'air 👍
-mettez un pouce bleu 👍
non mais arrête de me banané comme ça...
oui j'ai dit le mot banané
ça confirme 2018 ?
-oui banané ,banané reviens en..
le premier janvier, une très bonne nouvelle pour les bananes
oui alors en fait je cherchais un mot  has-been  pour dire que c'etait cool
-c'est bath
c'est bath !! oui !! comme guillaume, c'est bath
-guillaume bats
et si tu vois la référence *dab**dab**dab**dab*
-euhhh
par là : *dab*
merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
merci beaucoup aàLola Dubini d'être venue !!
-merci à toi de m'avoir invitée
mais par contre vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo qu'on a tournée ensemble
-hm hm
parce-que vous avez déjà oublié sa donc je vous le rappelle y'a une vidéo sur la...
...chaine de Lola, lien dans la description n’hésitez pas a visiter sa chaine
à vous abonner parc -que c'est en plus
une super chaine et une super euh...
fille, femme, meuf tout ce que tu veux
euh c'est aussi un peu dans mon cœur ma marraine de YouTube
*calin* qu'est-ce que je l'aime
Fabien c'est l'un des rares à mériter tout ce qui lui arrive
donc j’espère que tu couperas pas ça au montage
mais tu mérites tout ce qui t'arrive et je suis très très très fière
de voir ce qui se passe pour toi j'suis très contente
eh beh je suis très gêné c'est très pratique
*rires* oui c'est.. c’était  l'idée d'être gênante
tu m'as gêné avec ce jeu aussi
embrassez vous vous-mêmes parce-qu'on est pas là pour le faire et on aimerai le faire mettez un petit pouce abonnez vous et a très bientôt
tchau (ou ciao)